carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde parís
bienvenidos a este nuevo número de
carrusel de las artes en el que les
hablaremos de un personaje histórico de
fotografía cine y de música francesa
la vileta acoge una vasta exposición
sobre napoleón bonaparte en el año del
bicentenario de su muerte una muestra
que aborda las luces y sombras de un
personaje aún hoy controvertido
las mujeres migrantes en tiempos de kobe
de cesc el tema de una serie fotográfica
de la francesa agnès de aves quien viajó
a ecuador para este trabajo carrusel de
las artes conversó con ella en los
estrenos de cine the french despacha la
fantasía imaginada en francia- por wes
anderson y la fractura de catherine
corsini un drama con trasfondo social y
en nuestra crónica musical les
presentamos a slim and the beast o un
trío masculino de armonías vocales con
un estilo que nos transporta a los años
[Música]
la polio por aparte reina en el centro
de exposiciones de la habilidad en el
norte de parís se trata de una vasta
exposición en el marco del bicentenario
de la muerte de buena parte un personaje
polémico pero que ha fascinado a lo
largo de la historia
tan admirado como controvertido a
napoleón bonaparte es un personaje
complejo una figura histórica que oscila
entre heroísmo y sed de conquista
victorias militares y trágicas derrotas
modernismo y regresión en el
bicentenario de su muerte parís organiza
una vasta exposición que explora las
luces y sombras de este personaje mítico
la problema fácil
napoleón ha fascinado siempre fue
alguien que venía de una familia
relativamente modesta de la isla de
córcega a sus 30 años era el jefe
absoluto de francia para luego
conquistar casi toda europa y colocar a
miembros de su familia en los diferentes
tronos en el continente y todo eso en
muy poco tiempo en apenas 14 años
napoleón iba a la velocidad de la luz 13
pase a la vista es de leclerc
la muestra en la villette reúne objetos
que pertenecieron a napoleón como la
espada de la consagración y numerosos
recursos audiovisuales para entender su
personalidad compleja y polémica
[Música]
y las cosas napoleón era autoritario eso
es incontestable no le gustaba que lo
contra dijeran ni tampoco a las
discusiones pero tampoco fue un tirano
napoleón se sometió al sistema heredado
de la revolución donde las decisiones se
tomaban en asamblea es absurdo pensar
que un solo hombre podía reinar sobre 35
millones de personas sin tener aliados y
sobre todo sin enemigos en esta
exposición explicamos que la
organización política del consulado y
del imperio fue con muy sofisticada y
que no fue para nada una dictadura como
muchos la cataloga
la exposición de la villette también se
refiere a una de las facetas más
polémicas de napoleón su carrera militar
y su sed de conquistar nuevos
territorios aunque se recuerda también
su contribución en el campo civil
[Música]
pero las victorias militares en las
batallas de austerlitz y elena o bagram
le permitieron dominar a europa
sucedieron luego de 1805 es decir un año
después de ser proclamado emperador
antes de eso la potencia había ilustrado
en el ejercicio del estado en el sentido
civil del término fue el artífice de
profundas reformas civiles legales y
constitucionales
entonces es necesario relativizar además
todas las potencias europeas de la época
eran imperialistas todos los países
estaban de acuerdo en hacerse la guerra
en el fondo lo que habría que reclamar a
napoleón es haber sido el mejor en ese
campo lo cobraría un
especial acreedor
[Música]
y una fotógrafa francesa documentó la
crisis de los migrantes principalmente
mujeres en ecuador les invitamos a
descubrir este trabajo exhibido en el
último festival visa publimar de
fotoperiodismo
la crisis de los migrantes y de la
comida en ecuador la fotógrafa francesa
agnès de aves puso su objetivo en esta
zona del mundo para relatar en imágenes
la precariedad de muchas mujeres madres
y jóvenes personas vulnerables que huyen
de países como venezuela o colombia para
comenzar una nueva vida en otro lugar
este trabajo formó parte de la
exposición colectiva doble pena los
refugiados en la crisis sanitaria
presentada en el festival vida por el
imas de perpignan
y
cuando llegue a ecuador puede conocer a
personas que eran víctimas de la
violencia en sus países de origen y que
se enfrentaban también a la crisis por
el coronavirus escuché historias muy
duras pero al mismo tiempo muy
inspiradoras mis familias enteras
mujeres jóvenes madres niños pequeños
para todas el objetivo era muy claro
acceder a una nueva vida para ellas y
para sus familias en ecuador rojo
[Música]
no existe es el balón su logo portas
entonces en mis fotos quise reflejar
esas dos posturas la vulnerabilidad del
migrante y a la vez su fuerza para
comenzar desde cero con todo lo que la
crisis del cúbito implicaba
gracias a la ayuda de ongs locales años
de árabes visitó varios refugios para
migrantes y desplazados en ecuador donde
la precariedad convive con los deseos de
superación
[Música]
desde hace casi dos años estamos
viviendo esta crisis sanitaria con todas
las restricciones de libertad que hemos
tenido pero hay personas en el mundo que
sufren se caen se levantan y
reconstruyen su vida yo quería mostrar
esa resiliencia a veces nos hablan de
los migrantes con un discurso muy
negativo y trágico pero no fue lo que
encontré en ecuador al contrario lo que
vi fue muy inspirador y no me lo
esperaba
pasamos ahora a nuestro bloque dedicado
a los estrenos de cine con dos películas
que estuvieron en la última selección
del festival de cine de cannes y que nos
presenta ya mismo melissa barra
especiales al aire
y el aclamado director estadounidense
wes anderson irrumpe en las salas de
cine con the friends dispatch o una
película hablada en inglés pero filmada
en la ciudad francesa de angulema
frente dispares una colección de relatos
cortos sacados de un diario imaginario
en una ciudad imaginaria omnivisión blas
de que evoca al parís de los 50 los
periodistas de este diario relatan
historias amenas como la de un psicópata
que termina siendo un genio del arte los
acontecimientos de mayo del 68 o una
crónica gastronómica
no tienes café
se trata de una fantasía francés al
mejor estilo de wes anderson
protagonizada por una lluvia de
estrellas de hollywood y algunas
celebridades francesas como timothée
salame le hace de marchamalo x
[Música]
ah
no la actualidad francesa más reciente
es el escenario de la fractura de
catherine corsini esta cinta coral narra
la ruptura de una pareja en un hospital
parisino al borde del colapso mientras
en la capital se desarrolla una violenta
protesta de los chalecos amarillos
el hospital público es el escenario
donde conviven distintas capas sociales
de reivindicaciones aspiraciones
carencias y relatos de una población
francesa al borde de la ruptura
[Música]
y ya con nosotros en el estudio natalio
olivares para la crónica musical de
oyola natalia hola y hoy vamos a
explorar contigo a un trío de músicos
que se ha hecho un lugar en la escena
indie pop francesa y desde las calles
del barrio 15 de parís nos vamos a subir
a una nube e ir hasta las estrellas del
cielo de parís a descubrir a un trío ese
final que se llama theme and the beast y
nos hablarán de su disco bill y
[Música]
nos sentimos como una familia ya hay dos
hermanos gemelos aquí y aún sin tener la
misma sangre hay una fraternidad entre
nosotros tres existe una expresión
inglés ya que es ser hermanos pero de
madres diferentes pues así somos
nosotros y lo fue desde el principio
desde que nos conocimos primero a través
del deporte que nos unió luego la
amistad y después con la música son tres
actividades o tres pasiones muy fuertes
[Música]
tres voces y un destinos tres voces la
de dos gemelos aaron y samuel y el amigo
o genial que se conocieron de casualidad
en la calle jugando basquetbol y desde
entonces no se sueltan y la aventura los
llevó a hacer ese disco vil y vil y que
habla de la búsqueda de la familia del
alza para el disco o el pp vil y habla
en general de la aventura que consiste
en buscar a su familia la canción tonta
de lengua amarrada y en particular
cuenta como una persona que no sabe
hablar muy bien en francés o en español
y trata de salir adelante el álbum pues
cuenta eso una frustración pero también
unas ganas inmensas de encontrar a
alguien familiar ese superarse ir más
allá porque llevamos más de un año y
medio encerrados y el disco habla sobre
todo de la búsqueda del viaje que lleva
hacia la familia
[Música]
sí no
y escuchar a los embistes como viajar a
borde de una nube de algodón y para
llegar a este estilo bien particular
hubo muchas muchas inspiraciones
la verdad tenemos muchas influencias
musicales como big beatles o crosby
stills and nash por ejemplo u otras más
modernas
por ejemplo los parciales timing para la
and the south o frank ocean es difícil
nombrarlos a todas y tenemos mucha
suerte en realidad de poder usar esas
músicas y al final poder tocar lo que
tocamos
[Música]
billy de los links and the beast o un
nuevo disco que se escucha en todas las
plataformas y tengo que decir es un trío
celeste bueno muchísimas gracias natalia
y para justamente escuchar un poquito
más de ese billy de slim and the bees
los vamos a dejar con esta canción
agradeciendo el es por su amable
sintonía y esperando que nos escuchen y
nos vean la próxima semana está guay
ah
en seco
avan
[Música]
ah
bien
y
[Música]